[Música]
es el momento de hablar de economía con
Daniela Blandón Daniela Buen día para
usted Hola Buenos días Ángela feliz
inicio de semana Igualmente para ustedes
Daniela los precios del petróleo
amanecieron al alza después de que los
grandes productores anunciaran recortes
y con un gran repunte Ángel a los
precios de las referencias brent de
Europa y wti del Golfo de México que son
las más utilizadas en todo el mundo
suben más del 2% muy por encima de los
70 dólares por barril con la referencia
europea asomándose ya casi a los 80 esto
como respuesta al anuncio de la OPEP más
que agrupa a la Organización de Países
exportadores de petróleo y aliados
encabezados por Rusia de que van a
reducir sus objetivos de producción a
partir de 2024 más detalles sobre este
anuncio en el siguiente informe de
Ramiro cuevarena
el bloque de 23 países productores de
crudo que integran la Organización de
Países exportadores de petróleo la OPEP
se reunió en Viena y comunicó la
extensión de los recortes en la
extracción de barriles de crudo para
sostener los precios los cuales han ido
a la baja en los últimos meses además
Arabia Saudita informó una reducción
extra de un millón de barriles por día
los países que habían acordado hacer los
recortes voluntarios lo han extendido
hasta finales de 2024 y tendré que
llamarlo la piruleta saudí que es un
millón de barriles de reducción que
empieza el primero de julio y ese millón
también es prorrogable
la medida fue bien acogida por los demás
miembros de la organización la cual ha
decidido unilateralmente aminorar la
producción petrolera a pesar de los
reclamos de occidente para proteger el
valor de su principal bien de
exportación
agradecemos al reino de Arabia Saudita
por la bonificación adicional o el
recorte voluntario adicional que ha
mostrado este año
que ha demostrado lo importante que es
la estabilidad del mercado y lo
importante que es que vuelvan las
inversiones al sector a este importante
sector
Este es el tercer intento que la OPEP ha
impulsado en recortes en el último
semestre para Elevar el precio del crudo
hasta ahora sin resultados positivos de
lograrlo dada la importancia de la OPEP
a nivel global podría generar nuevos
aumentos mundiales en los costes de
gasolina Arabia Saudita necesita
incrementar sus ingresos para financiar
proyectos de diversificación de la
economía y alejarla del sector petrolero
vamos a cambiar de tema Daniela hoy se
lleva a cabo una reunión bien importante
de los líderes mundiales de la industria
aérea Ellos están reunidos en Turquía y
han dado unos anuncios que cambian el
panorama cuéntenos usted pues se lleva a
cabo la asamblea general de la
asociación Internacional del transporte
aéreo la industria reconoció que las
tarifas a nivel mundial sean elevados y
culpan de ello a los impuestos y a los
cargos adicionales que han agregado un
33% a los precios también a la inflación
a los precios de los combustibles para
avión y a los problemas en la cadena de
suministro las aerolíneas creen que
estos precios ayudarán este año a
recuperar las ganancias después de las
enormes pérdidas que generó la pandemia
aunque se prevé que transporten a más de
4.300 millones de pasajeros este año
dicen que todavía no es suficiente por
lo que
estamos viendo un entorno positivo para
2023 donde la rentabilidad es del orden
de 9.800 millones de dólares en la
industria Eso suena bien y es una gran
cifra pero cuando se considera que es
sobre una base de ingresos de más de 800
mil millones de dólares representa un
margen neto de 1,2% o en términos
simples alrededor de 2,25 dólares de
ganancia por pasajero que es menos que
el precio de una taza de café o un
boleto de metro
hay malas noticias para varias regiones
entre ellas América Latina Pues sí
miremos primero que la iata asegura que
aunque una ganancia neta de 2,2 dólares
por pasajero no es sostenible al menos
sí es mejor que los 76 dólares por
pasajero que perdieron en 2020 por culpa
de la pandemia pero esa rentabilidad
como es un cálculo promedio no aplica
igual para todos las regiones como Asia
Pacífico latinoamérica y África si van a
finalizar o por lo menos Esa es la
proyección que finalice en el año en
números rojos en concreto en nuestra
región se espera que las aerolíneas en
su conjunto pierdan 1.400 millones de
dólares con una demanda todavía 2% más
baja que antes de la pandemia y una
oferta también más reducida y sobre todo
si se empiezan a agrupar entre todas
pues la gente no va a querer viajar por
los precios tan altos Tendría que haber
otra solución Daniela Sí señora vamos a
cambiar de tema la sección de economía
se une al día mundial del medio ambiente
con un repaso por las principales cifras
del uso de plástico pues Ángela la
escala del problema y sus implicaciones
pueden notarse En las siguientes
estadísticas tomadas de la organización
para la cooperación y el desarrollo
económicos con cifras a 2019 Y es que
estamos produciendo 460 millones de
toneladas al año de plástico 353
millones de las cuales son residuos
plásticos esto también se puede ver en
los cinco años de vida útil que tienen
casi dos tercios de los plásticos
producidos principalmente los que
empacan los alimentos y
lo entre las toneladas producidas y las
toneladas de residuos quiere decir que
el 9% de los residuos están reciclando
falta mucho exactamente falta mucho por
reciclarnos esta reciclando el plástico
sabe que de todas esas cifras para mí la
peor es la de empaquetar las frutas y
las verduras en plástico todavía se
sigue viendo mucho muchísimo y dos y
tres capas de plástico bueno
se acabó por fin la novela del techo de
la deuda de Estados Unidos Eso no
significa que el problema se haya
terminado persiste por el contrario
persiste por el contrario porque por más
que el presidente Joe biden haya
sancionado el fin de semana el proyecto
que evitó que el país comenzara a dejar
de pagar sus obligaciones a partir de
hoy muchos ven esto como una solución de
corto plazo que está lejos de abordar el
verdadero problema en estas
negociaciones ambas partes dejaron
intacto el principal impulsor de la
deuda en Estados Unidos que es el
aumento de Los costos de las pensiones
del seguro social y también los
beneficios de salud de Medicare según la
oficina del presupuesto del Congreso se
proyecta que los costos del seguro
social van a aumentar 67% para 2032 y
que el programa de salud de Medicare
para personas mayores casi va a duplicar
Su costo durante este periodo Y eso por
qué pasa pues porque los estadounidenses
de 65 años o más van a representar el
46% de la población en ese entonces en
el 2032 frente al 34% actual según esas
mismas estimaciones todo esto se debe
Por supuesto al envejecimiento de la
población que es un problema que no
solamente afecta a Estados Unidos sino
al resto del planeta o a muchos países
pero muchísimos Daniela Cuál es la cifra
del día bueno Yo sé que no se la ha
visto y no le voy a hacer ningún
adelanto Porque además yo tampoco me la
he visto pero la voy a antojar
120,5 millones de dólares esta fue la
taquilla en Estados Unidos y Canadá el
fin de semana con el estreno de
spider-man across de spider-verse es la
segunda apertura nacional más grande de
2023 solamente por detrás de Super Mario
Bros en la película y superando
inclusive a Guardianes de la galaxia 3
que debutó con 118 millones dólares un
poquito por debajo de estos ciento
millones 120 millones de dólares que
estamos hablando también en el
extranjero esta película debutó con una
taquilla de más de 88 millones de
dólares para muchos esta saga es de lo
mejor que ha sacado esta tercera etapa
de las películas y de las series de
Marvel Bueno ya lo veremos y también hay
otra creo aproximándose de spider-man
también para esperemos sí acaba la
huelga de guionistas Daniela Bueno eso
es lo que también hay que ver Ángela
porque hemos hablado de la huelga de
guionistas inclusive hoy lunes se tienen
previsto que termine la votación de de
parte de los actores que se podrían unir
a los guionistas y todo esto sería
catastrófico para las series y las
películas No ahora sino dentro de un
tiempito lo vamos a ver incluido
spider-man Gracias Daniela más tarde nos
vemos más tarde nos vemos acá con más
economía